how to believe in yourself so I got a
really really awesome question for one
of my youtube viewers love you guys
Elias who wrote in to say hey I'm gonna
have a question that is very related to
your channel's main idea believe my
whole life I had a dream of becoming a
race driver since I was a little child
that would play anything with cars it
started out with silly arcade games -
real hardcore simulators over the years
they didn't settle with being good
enough I always wanted to be the best I
wanted to be number one now here's a
strange thing every time I go to the
track to watch the races whenever I talk
to the drivers I had the feeling that I
will never be able to do it again I have
the evidence of friends family saying I
do have the talent for this I'm really
good they say whenever I'm online racing
of the simulators I win a lot I'm always
a designated driver for emergencies this
racing thing possesses me I wake up but
it's the first thing I think about it so
now my question how do you start to
believe do you lie to yourself until you
start to believe it overall in life I
believe in myself but for this racing
aspect I just don't do as much yet I'm
good at it I feel as I know I suck where
the evidence is proven that I suck at
racing my life will be meaningless
without racing if you want to make a
video response about this first of all I
would love to thank you in advance but
there is no need to because I feel like
I would owe you something since I can't
return the effort I hope this wasn't too
long or boring great videos keep up the
good stuff thank you Eliza Eliza I am
happy to make a video response and it
touches a personal chord for me too
because I'm a big believer in that
you're limiting personal beliefs hold
you where you are we all have limiting
personal beliefs that hold you where you
are prevents you from doing great things
in your life because you tell yourself a
story that prevent you from moving
forward and this is something that I
constantly deal with as well I think
everybody does and you argue like this
and then plateau and then go like this
and then plateau and the the
breakthroughs are always when I bust out
and destroy one of my limiting personal
beliefs so there's a three-step process
that I think will help you
number one is awareness
awareness is just understanding that you
have a limiting personal belief and so
you've done this already you're already
a step ahead of most people because most
people will tell themselves that story
of I'm not good enough and and they just
believe it and they do nothing as a
result they don't get frustrated by it
they don't they don't change anything
they just stay in their life because
they feel like they're not good enough
for whatever big goal or big dream that
they had they can never be that race car
driver because they just tell themselves
are not good enough so step one is just
awareness and trying to catch yourself
whenever you find yourself thinking this
and the more you catch yourself thinking
in it the more it's gonna it's gonna
piss you off this is this is what helps
me every time I have a limiting personal
belief it often takes a while to
manifest for me to to recognize that I'm
doing this to myself and then the more I
recognize it the more pissed off I get
the more it happens the more I
self-sabotage
the more I get angry and pissed off and
the gets to the point where something
has to change like I am NOT this person
I cannot handle this anymore something
has to change so that awareness leads to
huge results but most people
self-sabotage their entire lives and
never know why because they don't have
that awareness so you are already ahead
of most people so that's number one
awareness number two is one step at a
time a big challenge for a lot of people
is you're here right you're starting off
you may have started here you've got
here but you want to be like you want to
be up here you want to be up here and
that gap seems too big it seems too big
the clothes and so you're putting
everything on it right racing you want
to be up here but you're so afraid to go
here that if you fail it's everything
you've lost your whole life you've lost
all meaning and so you don't do anything
and you stay down here where will it's
one step at a time you're not gonna get
from here to here you're not gonna get
from simulators to being the best on the
track that's not how it works right
how did you go from where you were to
being the best of simulators right you
work up you practice you get better one
step at a time and so that's what you
need to do
you need to go one step at a time what's
your next step
next up is just getting in the car and
doing a race you don't to be the best
this is not gonna be on TV right it's
and you're not gonna have a fan club or
anything yet and you may suck on your
first race that's part of the learning
process when you first try something you
suck at it
and then you get better it's not gonna
be the end of the world if you continue
to practice and push yourself you'll get
better just like you did with the
simulators just like you did with the
video games every time you started it
the first time you picked it up you
weren't winning every single race and
the more you play the more you practice
the better you got the same thing is
gonna happen when you get out there but
you got to just get in the car and enter
a race one just go and don't put so much
pressure on it and that one thing will
let you do another step and another step
another step I remember when I was
invited to speak at a conference in
Brunei it was my first big speaking gig
I had an audience of thousands of people
and it was being broadcast nationally
across the country is a huge event and I
never done anything that big and I was
kind of secretly hoping that they would
cancel on me you know I think I was
cancelled you don't have to come you
don't have to speak because I was so
nervous that what if I bomb then what if
I sucked and maybe I would never be able
to do this speaking thing again which I
love to do and I went up and it was good
it wasn't my best thing ever you know
I'm a lot better now than I was then but
people liked it
people liked the message people came up
to me and said how great it was
afterwards and that just doing that one
act now I mean it's so much easier for
me to go doing the next thing every
other speaking engagement has been easy
right because I already did that I've
gotten here so I can stay here staying
here is easy now it doesn't push me
doesn't stretch my comfort zone I've
done it before so it's easy to stay
there now if it was everyone wants you
to speak at a sold-out Madison Square
Gardens
I might get nervous again I might start
freaking out I might say I might start
secretly hoping that they cancel on me
right and and wreck
right back to wariness recognizing that
that is a limited personal belief if I
keep thinking about that it's going to
piss me off I'm gonna go and do it so
taking those little steps each time
gives you the confidence to go one more
and one more and one more and don't just
try to leap take those small steps to
get you there number three is your
environment this is so critical because
you are the product of your environment
you look at the people around you the
books you read that people you look up
to the mentors you have you are a
product of the people around you in your
life and you want to be like them it
happens right as people this is this is
what we tend to do you're the product of
your your best five friends and it's
great that your friends are supportive
and your family is supportive and
they're telling you hey you can do this
we believe in you that's great
but you need somebody to challenge you
you need somebody to to say that you're
great but you could be way better right
you need somebody to be on your case you
need somebody to to you know give you
some props for what you're doing but
saying this is still nothing man like
you have such a wide open net in front
of you what are you doing get in the
[ __ ] car and go race and it's great
that you don't have you know the little
man in your life you know the people
telling you you know why you can't make
it but sometimes that's good you know
sometimes that serves you as fuel what I
would look at is to you know if you
don't have the friends to push you start
reading about great people start reading
about great drivers and I don't know
their stories but you know look at
Michael Schumacher or the movie driven
right those two racecar drivers who are
battling it out look at the greatest
racers in history and look at their
story and look at the problems that they
had and and be inspired by what helped
get them there and surround yourself
with that pretend like Michael
Schumacher is your friend right that
might sound stupid but close your eyes
and imagine you're sitting on a table
with Michael Schumacher and and you're
asking this question what's he gonna
tell you is he gonna tell you sit on the
sidelines it's gonna tell you don't do
it no man he's gonna sing get in the
race right so you need people in your
life to challenge you and this is a
constant struggle you're asking this
question is a very personal question but
this is something that everybody goes
through and it's something that I
continues to go through I'm going
through this right now let me let me
share a personal story of mine I want to
have a huge impact this is what drives
me I wanna I want to have a big impact
and I know I can help people on a small
scale I know I can help you with the
videos and the videos are taking off and
everything I've done is you know it's
growing quickly but I want it to be
bigger right I want it to be
life-changing on a world scale and I
don't always believe that I can do it
because I've never done it before
because it seems like such a big goal
and I'm writing the book right now and
it's I wanted to be an important book I
wanted to be one of the the top 10 most
read most valuable business books of all
time and that's an easy goal to say
right anybody can say I want to have
this book to be the top ten book anybody
can say that but who actually believes
that right do I actually believe that I
can write that book because if I don't
I'm not going to write that book and
when I'm talking to people I'm not going
to get them excited and there's a fine
line between confidence and an arrogance
or cockiness but that's the challenge
that I'm going through right now
it's believing that I can create this
amazing book and when I'm talking to
Jessica Alba and saying hey you're you
know you're a superhero in the movies
but you should be a superhero in real
life as well you could be a superhero
for entrepreneurs and and help them and
be a model for success for your honest
company I have to do that with a lot of
confidence I have to do that believing
that this is truth I go through that
process - all the time
right the more I find myself frustrated
and and thinking that I can't do it I
get angry and eventually gets to the
point where like I can't handle
anymore and I'm I gotta just do it I got
a breakthrough because that that's that
belief is just in my head it doesn't
exist and then I start taking small
steps small steps to achieve my goal
right one chapter reach out to one
person they said yes okay let's go get
somebody else and build it up and then
create an environment that supports me I
surround myself and I have this
challenge in my business where there
aren't a lot of people in my life who
challenge me there are a lot of people
who challenge me to be better who have
done what I'm trying to do and say Evan
it's great like awesome what you've done
but do it like you're just scratching
the surface you should be up here man
here are the ten things you need to do
to get there and I surround myself with
people who I don't know you know like
Steve Jobs like jay-z people who have
built great things and have a lot of
confidence and wanna have a huge impact
I'm drawn to those people and I surround
myself with them and I will close my
eyes and imagine what Steve Jobs would
tell me or what jay-z would tell me what
Donald Trump might tell me and I use
that as fuel to help me keep going it's
a great question and one that you know
maybe we can't solve in one video but
every major breakthrough that you'll
make in your life comes from stepping
outside your comfort zone and shattering
one of your limiting personal beliefs
and it's hard and it sucks and it's
painful but when you get through it if
you look back and say well that was that
was stupid man that was nothing how is
that afraid of that and then if pattern
repeats itself all over again
so don't do those three steps and break
your limiting person beliefs so remember
step number one awareness step number
two one step at a time and step number
three your environment belief so those
are you watching you liked the video you
can subscribe to my channel see more
videos like this thank you so much I'll
see you soon